[Music]
how's it going bro my name is p welcome
back to the
moon in the last episode we went back in
time and we are two floating heads this
does not really make sense in my diary
but hey I don't even write a diary so
that's a little too early let's enter
from a bit further all right let's go
back up John don't worry about me I'm
just a flying
head okay let's go to the all this John
it's got to be this one
right we got to go through everything
again no that's
impossible I know we're here you this is
the same setting as his real last
accessible memory usually there's at
least some change something isn't
right these memories they feel more than
just having happen again what is going
on they are exactly the same that's
impossible it is side was transfer was
was it
not it
was oh what is going
on something did we mess something up
did we do something wrong with the
memories if this is indeed the same
memory he'd be at the cliff all
right oh yeah oh yeah
okay what if river is there that would
be
creepy
what is a bell is
there this is not the
same
Johnny what a pleasant surprise we don't
get many visitors around here D you
again my name is do dariva Roseline and
this
is what I'm not saying it
twice Dr
Neils are you familiar with the Sigman
agency of Life generation we have to do
this again oh are you two from the
agency how convenient I've just been
thinking of calling
you Lily get us some tea
please
Lily
oh freezing him
too
ah what is going
on
Wow wait here I go send the desire
signal again see if there's any
changes how the H how would I see that I
guess I can poke
him it's transferred successfully for
sure any
changes not even a
hair how could this be even if soci
doesn't work alone why is there no
change at all perhaps perhaps he just
needs some provoking to
activate from his early memories the
early as we can go to get to let's
go what I don't really understand what's
going on right now we're going back to
with the switch thing is this the
earliest it's not really the
earliest Johnny decid to go to the Moon
might H need some simulation to be
brought up huh well then oh that's the
desire oh okay now I get
[Music]
it the movie they were
watching what that this wasn't oh okay
she just
changed oh
well do you mind
[Music]
River no I like this one all right let's
go
then or maybe
not hopefully that's enough for an
ignition
wait where's Neil yeah where hell is he
probably munchy
watching did you see to the Moon how was
it eh it was a bit too much pretense for
me I prefer my moves a bit
morea I don't know what that mean b it
means you are gay
what okay
fine fine all right where the hell is
inside the
[Music]
cinema I
guess what are they doing why does a
platypus get an own seat to the Moon
ning Oh
Henry dear Lord I I'm way too tired and
hungry for constructive movies guess I
should go and see if anything's changed
with John well we don't even know where
he is I need to Traverse through JN okay
let's do that sorry John I'll just
borrow
this so now we get to see if anything
has changed this is so weird I
can't it's probably still nothing it's
all the same I'll have to try igniting
it somewhere else then this is
ridiculous get out of my way Lily sorry
sir I'm going to use you to go back in
time we going back in time back in time
okay here this is a good memory perhaps
something here could work the Platypus
oh
John so did she throw an in be in her
face huh did she shut up dude what are
you guys doing here I'm starting I'm
starting let's go get a good spot what's
starting wait I don't remember that
happening something must have
changed
okay hey don't
squeeze what is going on what is going
on what is going
on what are they
doing this has got to be
it where is Dr Watts wait a
minute this isn't a real change this is
may I have your attention
a what a you
doing come
on as you know I am a representative
send from NASA in all his glory Wow way
to be in subtle she did a couple posters
and I'm here to tell you all about it h
it
timy nice going Timmy wow that was
terrible but I digress come on
dude anyway I know many of you are
wondering what changes do I have of
doing something as awesome as
adventuring into another real to inhale
the sweetness of Venus to swim
counterclockwise through the rings of
Saturn or perhaps just chilling at the
backside of the
Moon well here at Nasa we believe that
with enough will everyone has the
potential he's so Rus it could be
you it could be or you or
perhaps yeah but I don't want to go to
the Moon then you're in L wait what why
not why should I I'm happy here on Earth
as it is well don't you want to go there
even a little bit no why not even a tiny
bit um no
come on dude you're doing it wrong it's
obv something about
River well as an official na recruiter I
should go over some facts about the moon
don't do it please just don't do it to
start out the Moon is 4.5 billion years
old oh of course good job this is going
to solve it as you did know that it
surface uh is as big as Africa okay it's
true in fact if you try to bike around
the
Moon also it takes 1.52 47 seconds for a
light to travel to the Moon from here
and if you drive a flying car it takes
130 days I knew
that
okay thank you for all these random fact
last but I need people who go to the
Moon get rich and famous and why we all
know that rich plus famous equals
groupies so that concludes my
presentation good presentations bravo
bravo V remember now welcomes any of you
especially if you're a
brunette come on
man and River never went anyway so this
is
pointless what's going on are they
beating each other up no they're
leaving well what do you think NASA
probably wouldn't hire you but I suppose
it was blatant enough for this H I do
try pretty hard are you going to go see
if that work of course be right back
that's not not going to work it's
obvious it's not going to work that's
not how it works back report utter
failure
Deuce hey don't get discouraged I'm sure
there are still things to be done such
as
well well
what
back here we can't afford to finish
building this houses a
b we can barely what but can you afford
the Luna trip
Lottery stop come on if you sell it to
you sure
can it's not going to work
bro is the diagnosis certain this is
terrible you shouldn't joke if yes in
fact did you know that NASA has
excellent healthcare plans it's true for
both of your spous seriously don't they
get it it's so
obvious I like free pony rid is INS
spair come on oh look a wedding good for
you but here's a riddle guess where you
should go for your honey
moon this is so stupid come
on that's a
bunny maybe this is something
good River
this is when he got the news uh when he
gave her the news I
guess come on DNA bite glass slippery
Johnny John
John come on what in the
Cucumber oh there we
go you know what this just isn't
working it's more than just not working
it's ridiculous well we're freaking
professionals I didn't sign up for the
job to run around yelling at him like an
idiot you
didn't H look maybe this lack of sleep
is getting to
us had I known that we'd been an all
nighter I brought coffee I agree you
should have seen the movie I constructed
earlier what
movie
exactly okay anyway as valuable as time
is here this just isn't going anywhere
like this let's take a break till
morning hopefully Johnny can hang on
until
then that's
pretty I do have some calls to
make
H but I thought they were technically
asleep when they were doing this it's a
little
weird and now we're
back
here no we should not be
here we should be here
what is going
on we're missing something
again jump scare it doesn't make sense
why did the machine have no
effect Johnny registered wish to go to
the moon was successfully transferred
yet there wasn't even a trace of he
wanted to go to the Moon after the
transfer why does he want to go to the
Moon unless unless a secondary condition
to desire was changed in the
process only then would the same desire
produce two different outcomes at two
different points in
time that's deep girl there's no denying
that River played an important role
through it all if there's anything we
could have caused to core change she
would be the top suspect well of course
it's her but out of all things what
exactly caused
it
River what exactly did you do
what did you do river only questions in
this game not going to lie it's crazy ah
the sun's Rising it's beautiful look at
that
gorgeous look at the birds they're like
hey how you
[Music]
doing we don't have much time
left I wonder if Neil came up with
anything like if you enjoyed this
episode Bros subscribe to Bro today I'll
see you next episode of wherever I make
hopefully next episode we'll find out
what is really going on I would love to
know please tell me anyway stay onome
bre oh you got one shoted
bit what
barrels yeah barel you [__]
barel
bar best [__] room
ever that's right BS